As we said earlier, PKI can be used for
many other purposes than
we've mentioned so far.
These include securing software until
you've entered the vendor's code
indicating you've paid for it,
securing wireless networks, digital
rights management for movies and music.
In reality,
PKI is more complex than described here.
The validation of the certificate
should be more robust,
something called extended validation.
To reduce the computational load,
there are so
called hybrid approaches that create
keys just for a specific session.
But this is probably not
sufficiently secure for health care.
Finally, there is the concern
about advances in computing.
We've assumed that given the Public Key,
it is too expensive and
time-consuming to
calculate the private key.
Proposed quantum computers
might change this.
And could lead to the need to
make major modifications for
encryption to remain useful.